so this morning she goes
uh coffee and donuts please you know and
I go okay I just donuts she was like
yeah
I go downstairs and like I know she
ordered something yesterday and she went
out yesterday and came back so I'm
looking on the counter I'm looking for
these Donuts I'm like where the donuts
at now I'm upset that I didn't see the
donuts last night because I would have
had a donut right looking looking so
then I'm downstairs I facetimer I go
babe I don't see no Donuts she goes yeah
I just thought you would go to the store
and get them
into going to get donuts by saying there
was donuts and she thought I'd be down
there so disappointed like there's no
Donuts let me get my keys and go drive
and get her Donuts like
oh man so that's just that's that's my
life